david lowery the director of Pete's
dragon is now adapting the green knight
i got with me the outlaw nation leader
himself John Roca how you doing John I'm
doing great thanks Greg I'm excited to
come back a bit on really injects a
couple times so I mean you said come
here early in the morning to come see
this Green Knight trailer so I drove
here at 5 a.m. and the door to come to
your house to watch this thing before
you go to the Sen live so I'm looking
forward to it but this video will be up
after he's done with se unless I got his
appearance on Sen live mode on
Entertainment Network but more
importantly John Roca has his own
YouTube channel they quickly sorted
10,000 subscribers and what like an hour
yeah something like that
it was insane he is doing daily videos a
lot of live streams it's great stuff
yeah and as a very endearing to my heart
I love this man I'm saying
so these please do check out his channel
and we wanted to bring him on for a
while but I wanted him to get his
channel off the ground for a while first
me I guess earn your way back here real
rejects mr. Roca that's a fair point
fair yeah thanks for doing it it's John
Roca says that's the chance you know
obviously YouTube and address there but
yeah I come and entertainment got Pro
Wrestling stuff got my live streams in
the morning movie reviews trailer
reactions the whole night it's all in
there and sports stuff as well on the
side that I'm starting to do now as well
so there's gonna be a lot of stuff
coming down the pike even more so not
interested in the movie stuff but sports
and wrestling is all me alright let's do
this
[Music]
that's badass I was want to narrate him
when they ever yeah when honor was
everything Dev Patel and I love this
8:24 loves setting people on fire he's
holding the Holy Hand Grenade let's
totally go out of here Wow
[Music]
here listen vikander
badass oh is that joel edgerton yeah
got a little wolf in there oh I should
have done some research okay great is
that this is inspired by yeah the nephew
yes oh the tail of the Sir Gawain and
the Green Knight is obviously Arthurian
tail which is pretty awesome Gawain is
the headstrong nephew of King Arthur and
he is like the Green Knight shows up to
Camelot one day all the Knights are
there the round table and Arthur and he
says I'm not even gonna challenge you
fools because none of you can hold a
candle to what I can do but I'm gonna
let one of you take a strike at me with
an axe and I won't fight back as long as
I can return the blow a year and a day
later so none of the Knights want to
take this guy on because look at it look
at the look of it yeah they don't want
to take him on
Arthur is about to do it and then Gawain
steps up and says no I got this chief
I'm gonna take care of business takes
the axe and he cuts off the Green
Knights head with one slice of the axe
the Green Knight without skipping a beat
picks up his head holds it gets back on
a source and says I'll see you in a year
in a day at the green castle
so this tale is about all the stuff he
goes through going does on his way and
his journey to the green castle over a
year and a day so it seems like what we
see in the trailer that's Arthur and
Guinevere sending him off on this
mission to discover who he is and in the
tale Morgan la Fey gets involved too as
a mother of more than the half-sister of
Arthur all these kind of witchcraft gets
involved in all this kind of stuff so I
want to ruin anything I don't know how
close they're gonna adhere to that tale
but it's pretty awesome I'm so glad I
say all right let's make a jump cut here
and look up some
for medicine you say Guinevere and then
suddenly that's not a great night Tyler
I'm like oh yeah
vaguely reminiscent of this tale what I
can say is first off this feels like
pure a24 yeah like a hundred percent
that deliberate pacing that ominous sort
of oppressive horror menacing tone
underlying throughout the whole thing
the cinematography every 8:24 movie
feels like hereditary and then bursting
into flames yeah this is such an 8 24
things to do I like that they're taking
a horror approach to this you know
you're like in the hands of any other
movie studio you get you know the Kai
Richie version who alright or the Anton
Fuko version which I think has become
more beloved over time but I think this
is a nice direction to go and it's funny
because King Arthur and set that the
tale of King are it done so many
renditions of it none of them seem to be
working
so I feel like to do a completely
different take on it and not necessarily
about King Arthur himself focus on this
storyline is a really cool idea and also
this feel this doesn't feel low budget
but it's a 24 so you know it's not like
big budget either feels like contained
and scary yeah yeah I like that very
much like a character study of this guy
right what a movies - yeah it's a mood
piece totally I mean everything's off
kilter and askew and then you hear the
the sound of that wheel clicking around
what is that gonna signify and of course
that opening intro with in essence like
a halo that you see in those old
paintings yeah helos yeah and it's flame
is very medieval and this head bursts on
fire which is of course a reference to
the head getting chopped off and we see
that in the puppet show of course no I
thought yeah of course right there with
you yeah but I I like it it's like it's
dark it's like going like into the
horror elements like you said and we
don't know what's gonna happen
plus I love this idea of the colorblind
casting this is an Indian guy yeah yeah
Dev Patel playing the nephew of King
Arthur you know is it's the and that's
the actor from the James Bond series
and just insert my Airbender joke video
it's good timing and I totally messed it
up to another point and then got a beer
of course is Lisa Aaron from Game of
Thrones so nice to see her being a part
of this but yeah that's badass and david
lowery did old man in the gun and ghost
story which were a cool smaller films
about Pete's dragon which did have a
fantasy vibe to it it did who is the
producer at 8:24 you know I don't
actually know but hey they have they go
in and they're like no you gotta do it
like this single you got it has to feel
and look like this yeah yeah no it does
look absolutely beautiful you know who
alicia vikander's playing whoa I don't
wanna give too much away but in the
story he ends up at this castle with
that that is about maybe two miles away
from the green castle right near the end
of his journey there's a young girl
there and she tries to seduce him every
night in exchange for the spoils of the
hunt
that's a deal that he goes into with the
king of the castle she's the daughter
but then you find out there's all this
kind of witchcraft going on something
with a magical girdle there's all kinds
of weird stuff going on in this thing so
she might be playing that daughter of
the people at that castle so that's
interesting yeah I can totally relate
yeah tarot card thing though that's kind
of yeah I get the witchcraft or vibe to
it as well this is cool I love the I
love the atmosphere I love the
unsettling vibes it has throughout deaf
Patel I'm excited that he gets to do a
role like this he had Slumdog
Millionaire he's had a couple of decent
movies lion was good yeah but then he's
out you know his head is like chappies
in herbage yeah so this looks like a way
to really about like get back in that
spotlight because he's a wonderful actor
so yes hell yeah alright guys well thank
you so much for being here what did you
think of this trailer do you have the
utmost faith in a 24 it gets so many
views on their trailers and barely
anyone watches their movies go watch
this movie when it comes out would you
subscribe click that notification bell
follow mister
John Roca on his YouTube channel link in
description box link in the pin comment
last but not least patron of the days
showed got a different John to shout out
Pete Don Pete done another fellow writer
who is a longtime patron Jack supporter
so with that in mind there another
little poem these are always so
sentimental his name is Pete short for
Peter he's got really big feet
his little Peter is even bigger the
night is darkest before the dawn
his parents consider him to be the
greatest of their spawn Peter is also
the name of a man with the last name
Griffin a Peter dawn rides his own
successful fan fiction he's a longtime
supporter of the real rejects he will
forever have my respect him and I love
to connect and his work keeps me erect
that as in like my character wise you
know straight rigid and straight in
there yeah I'm straight narrow up
straight up right and I mean the
physical right citizen thing I don't
want to get yellow and dollar
I just mean no erect is a perfectly
natural vocab word to use you know an
erector set even